freunde herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video hier aus der wahrscheinlich
schönsten küche auf youtube ich bin bei
luca und ihr kennt ja vielleicht das
video ich mache sogar ersten bürger der
welt und ich mache über die beste pizza
der welt das hier ist ich mal lukas
besser sandwich der welt okay es ist
vielleicht nicht das beste
das ist eine serie es ist jetzt eine
serie geworden ist es auf jeden fall das
beste ist was ich machen kann und das
beste sandwich was ich je gegessen habe
sind große worte aber es ist wirklich
unfassbar
die inspiration zu diesem match kam von
kenji lopez das ist ein amerikanischer
politik über mein absoluter favorit auf
youtube das sandwich es bedeute machen
ist ein blt sandwich ihr kennt
vielleicht wenn ihr mein persönlicher
koch format verfolgt und wir fangen an
indem wir tomaten waschen ich habe mir
zwei hände voll tomaten geholt das sind
sehr kleine tomaten das liegt aber wir
haben jetzt gerade dezember und die
großen tomaten sind einfach nicht so ja
so geschmacksintensiv wie die kleineren
bist du ein bisschen mehr arbeit zu
schneiden aber für die textur letzten
endes auch dem sandwich macht überhaupt
keinen unterschied also dann wie gesagt
die tomaten schneiden wir in scheiben
und davor entfernen wir den strom weil
wir wollen natürlich nichts was
irgendwie ansatzweise hart ist später
auch unsere mannschaft außer vielleicht
knusprigen bacon ist aber auch ein gutes
stichwort denn wie heißt zum beispiel
unseren backofen vor und zwar auf 200
grad ober unterhitze wir es gesehen aus
dem knopf drücken damit der backofen auf
geht kommt der kredit und da rein kommt
nichts weiter als ein backblech ohne
papier also alles andere kommt aus in
der maschine backofen zu und den lassen
wir jetzt vorhalt sind fast entspannt
haben wir keinen backpapier nehmen das
ist nicht weil ich bloß artig bin und
das backblech direkt machen will nein
erstens wie gesagt das wird nicht
dreckig und zweitens wenn der becken
direkt aufs backblech kommt wird er
deutlich knuspriger und wir brauchen
knusprigkeit bayerisches geht es
natürlich vor allem um textur
das sind alles stellschrauben an denen
gedreht können ohne besondere textur zu
bekommt und ansonsten sind natürlich die
einzelnen zutaten die man verwendet im
sommer sind zwar gut so körbe wirft
tomaten und
im winter sind es auf jeden fall hier
die kleineren die sehr gut geeignet sind
hier kommt der nächste wichtige schnitt
feine scheiben für die beatsteaks keine
tomatenscheiben das gibt nämlich auch
noch eine ganz besondere textur und
seine sachlichkeit sage ich mal zu dem
sandwich deshalb ganz wichtig fein
schneiden wir sehr gespannt welche
besucher wird auf jeden fall sehr
ehrlich sein in seiner bewertung wie er
das in ordnung wird weil luca ist ein
großer sandwich fans so viel weiß ich
auch motorola pro wir uns kennengelernt
habe vor zehn jahren also hat ja immer
bei einem kaffee sind club sandwich
bestellt und so
er liebt es auf jeden fall sehr
dementsprechend bin ich glaube ich auf
einem guten weg bei dem wenn es jetzt
gemacht zusagt und breiten wir hier
unsere tomaten aus so dass wir gleich
wir wissen jeder einzelne tomaten
scheibe erwischen können und dann ist
auch schon soweit ganz brett schwimmt
quasi frisch gemahlener pfeffer wenn ihr
könnt ansonsten geht es auch so voll
gemein dafür fällt auf jeden fall besser
als kein treter wohnt seiten nicht so
krass übertreiben weil natürlich der
becken der später darauf kommt es auch
sehr salzig wir wollen ja nicht
versetzen
da stelle ich dann immer ich weiß nicht
ob es sinn macht aber ich stellte anna
lisa rettl es marinieren
ich habe nicht das gefühl dass die
tomaten diesen ganzen geschmack
aufsaugen und man kann jetzt auch schon
mal so ein bisschen vermengen ich weiß
nicht ob ihr jetzt mal ausprobiert habe
eine tomate gesalzen und nicht gegessen
sind welchen unterschied wirklich so
stellt die seite der backofen ist heiß
dann sollten wir in den backofen nicht
hervor
dann kaufen darauf achten dass hier
möglich zickenkrieg nachteil
wieder zu machen und jetzt kommt gar
nicht so sehr offene zeitangabe oder so
ein sondern wir behalten den werken
einfach im blick und sehen dann waren
eher crispy geworden ist da kommt ihr
auch schon so finaleinzug wir haben
werken wie tomate und es fehlt noch das
geld was ist los also salat und ich
benutze dafür gerne romane salatherzen
und da wiederum wirklich nur sowie
inneren blätter die extrem knusprig sind
und die schwelle ich keine chance ein
humaner salat reicht da auch schon das
wäre noch eine finale zu tat und zwar
mayonnaise kenji also der youtuber vom
anfang geht sogar so weit dass er sagt
es ist ein mayonnaise ist ein frisch
zusammen mit tomate salat und bacon ihr
könnt euch quasi ableiten wie viel
mayonnaise oder letztendlich darauf
kommt wir gucken mal beim welken rhein
wird schon sehr christi auf jeden fall
und was ihr hier seht dass das fett
rauskommt ist essentiell wir werden
nämlich gleich unser toastbrot dass wir
natürlich brauchen werden nämlich nicht
klassisch toasten sondern gewähren ist
in birkenfeld knusprig backen mit
strömendem regen der sich komplett durch
gewandhaus nehmen und zum abtropfen auch
zähmen und hinweg entdeckt ja auch von
oben ab damit wirklich das gesamte feld
raus geht so und dann wird es auch schon
zeit für unsere sample scheibe ziel hier
einmal durch und dann gehe ich schon auf
die andere seite hier genau das gleiche
dadurch soll möglichst am start sein und
richtig fett abbekommen haben
und dann machen wir das ist eine kleine
ecke von dem becken wird weitergemacht
haben hört mal hin
so leute dann ist es auch schon soweit
wir holen jetzt die toastscheiben aus
was soll ich sagen
von beiden seiten angegriffen noch
weichen der mitte das sind die
toastscheiben rostig müsst ihr nicht
machen ist nur wenn ihr sehr perfekt
machen wollte wie ich jetzt gerade
wir brauchen mayo das gesamte sandwich
soll und muss bedeckt sein
auf beiden seiten und das sandwich ist
jetzt richtig richtig knusprig liebe
tatsächlich die wahrheit im tomaten und
so natürlich nur einer aber am ende
haben wir durch
perfekte textur machen eine untere
schicht mit unserem romana salat bildet
eine gute grundlage
dann kommen unsere tomaten jetzt leute
keine zurückhaltung die tomaten sind
leichter dieser faktor wenn man rein
weil es nicht so denkt 'oh mein gott was
habe ich da gerade gegessen warum kannte
ich das noch nicht mehr ganzes leben
lang also wirklich komplett voll packen
das ganze dann kommt auch schon auf die
gegenseite der star der show unser
denken die zerfällt hier während ich ihn
zurecht rücken
jetzt ist es nur noch zeit die
senderchefin zusammenzufügen
und das hier ist die königin der
sandwiches wo ganz wichtig in dreiecke
schneiden
[Musik]
die mich direkt erinnern aber wegen
urlaub aber in deutlich besser der
ersten die im urlaub manchmal wenn wir
zu emma gegessen aber jetzt nicht mehr
weil ich nicht mehr so gut schmecken
die toten hatten mittlerweile sogar
nicht mehr das tust mir einfach so lasch
drauf aber wirklich die königin der
sandwiches land so was ihr das ist jetzt
alles drauf ein blt sandwich bacon
leider tomato und mario ich bin so
gespannt was zu sagen wird ohne käse
ohne schicken ohne gesonderte okay ich
bin gespannt darf ich das skript zum
entpacken der geraten doch ehrlich
gesagt das ist mal wieder für mich
gekocht ist soweit der welt sehr wild
world und noch mal und noch mal lecker
trip den tier david uci das ist der ja
das ist so wild entschlossen zum
frühstück staaten geben würde würde
immerhin gehen was den soldaten dass das
so krank ist aber ich mag das nicht wenn
so sei es durch krank sind dass du seist
du tust du richtig weh am glauben das
ist nun mal die komplette konsistent
dann ist es eigentlich sonderlich gesund
wegen dem fed und der mai und dem becken
aber schmeckt - besonders man fühlt sich
so es wird noch etwas gesundes essen
sehr gut weil dieser salat so knackig
ist es ist halt auch unnötig früh war es
eine stunde vorher einkaufen sagt ja ich
habe vorher wirklich hätte ich gedacht
ein sandwich so ohne irgendwie
geschmolzenen käse oder schinken oder
keine ahnung wie wir drauf der hilfe da
fehlt was aber da fehlt nichts das habe
ich aber genau das habe ich auch gesagt
dass mir die bürger gemacht habe ich
auch nichts gefehlt hat ich finde
wirklich das ist das beste los angeles
geht sehr leid dass die geschmeckt hat
dadurch seinen luca ist das handy ganz
in ruhe auf lass dir schmecken bin sehr
happy mit dem resultat und wir sehen uns
am sonntag wieder